okay so this question comes from steve
cambion of truth seekers and i'll put a
link to his podcast in the description
given the debate about your involvement
with atip and your actual role
would you be able to prove your
leadership role by releasing tax forms
tax forms in short could you simply
release your tax form tax forms to prove
your employment leadership role and your
salary for those years
of course i could but tax forms just
tell you you're working at a particular
office that's all it does
um and of course then you know you you
start
people start
looking at your your salaries and start
you know making all sorts of inferences
the bottom line is that the government
has already validated verified that i
work uh within the usdi
um the senator reed has already
validated work on on atip
you had the spokesperson for the
pentagon dana white under um under the
secretary
mattis already verified that i was
working a tip you have jim lycasky
verifying i worked in rana atip you have
i mean the list goes on and on and on
and on no i'm not going to get into a
tip for chad um you know if you
don't want i mean that on the world's
greatest clairvoyant because everything
i've talked about has come to fruition
to include the release of the videos
that are on the 1910 with my signature
both are remarkable
i mean at this point if if people still
question that then you know i i don't
know what to tell you um you know
go get a hobby you know no i'm not i'm
not going to sit here at this point in
time
uh you know there's an ig evaluation and
investigation specifically because of of
how they mishandled this and then they
come out and they say oh by the way we
deleted all those emails i mean if
you're that much of a sucker and you
actually you know still at this point
are are at all questioning what my role
is then
you know i'll tell you
sorry
okay this question comes from ina etter
question for lou what can we do
personally to prepare ourselves
and perhaps even other
post disclosure world
are we taking a break you need to no no
actually i was trying to find an email
but uh that
never mind i had an email that i've
never shown but i was about to say here
boom how's that for proof but no don't
worry about it i don't even want to get
into that it's you know what
we'll talk about that potentially i'm
not going to satisfy anybody's at this
point questioning you know it's all that
is is and by the way as time goes on
even more evidence is coming so you know
you find it to be a distraction and a
waste of time we have much greater
issues well and at this point it's just
insulting it's like dude i can't think
for you at this point i mean if at this
point you're still on the fence on that
then
you know
find something else to do because it's
yeah it's it it would be like seeing
obama's birth certificate and then
saying that he's still from kenya you'd
be like what more do you want from me
yeah it's like dude what more do you
want you have the guy who ran the
program the senator himself saying i ran
it i mean you had the pentagon say now
you have 60 minutes who by the way
backed it up with general mattis himself
i'm like
what more you want i mean
you want a video of me going in out of
the office when i was there well you're
not going to get that you know sorry
you know unfortunately there's a lot of
people out there that are still
i i consider agent provocateurs they're
just trying to to to confuse the
situation and for whatever reason you
know i mean
rather than looking at the last four
years and say wow look how far we've
come
you know they rather go back and and you
know it's